as we await the senior members of the
royal party let's just reflect on some
of those that have already arrived uh
the prime minister boris johnson arrived
with his wife carrie what reception did
they get
[Music]
[Applause]
i think we call that a mixed reception
in the trade so kia stammer has also
arrived
the leader of her majesty's opposition
not without challenges himself at the
moment as durham police send him a
questionnaire to ask him to explain
about the events of april 2021 in durham
[Music]
a much warmer reception for the princess
royal princess anne who um
arrived
with her family
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and edward and sophie wessex also
arriving with their two children
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
harry and megan
yes
and wasn't it interesting to see
and hear
the reaction
to them
and of course this is the first big
national occasion where we have seen
them in public with other members of the
royal family the last was
of course over two years ago now the
commonwealth day service
and
i think there were a mixture of cheers
and booze
i think the couple would know that that
was inevitable they have become
controversial characters
well for the prince of wales to
represent his mother at such a
significant national service
will be very poignant because of course
he's stepping in where he can to support
the queen in this period where her
mobility issues are much more profound
but to have the duchess of cornwall at
his side who was invested with the
insignia of the order of the garter by
the queen a couple of days ago her sign
of affirmation
to the prince of wales and the duchess
of cornwall after all uh the queen
stepped in and said that she saw
that it would be a great pleasure to her
to think that when her son succeeds as
king that his wife would be queen
at his side duke of cambridge wearing
the guard star here is a cheer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the biggest year of the day
by
some margin
right we as promised we thought we'd
have a little wander around alistair's
with me there's an awful lot of people
here hi everybody did you manage to see
any of the royals
did you uh yes we did but we our view
was not as uh great because we were a
bit far away but we saw them getting out
the cars and into the cathedral and
everyone was just so delighted to see
them it's such a happy occasion and a
bit of a one-off
you're fro where did you come from north
west london so not very
it was fantastic and i think
for you did you see anybody who you
recognize or were you stuck just a
little bit um i was able to see megan
and harry just a peek of them and
princess beatrice and eugenie as well
kate and william came very quickly we're
excited to see all of them fantastic yes
yeah the exact same that's we just saw a
little glimpses so we're hoping to see
them when they walk out of the church if
that's possible excellent these lovely
people here hi who did you manage to see
uh please say harry and megan and prince
willian and and kate yeah yes where did
you come from um come from london from
west london yeah i was here very early
in the morning yeah and i'm very happy
to be here it's a lovely occasion yeah i
love the queen and i love the royal
family oh fantastic well you were
rewarded with a good yeah
thank you very much should we carry on
more yes
so um alistair only a glimpse of people
well i i think that's the problem with
that's the trouble with television
yeah they went in their car and i saw
her and woke up there yeah
are you pleased to see them yeah i like
her megan's dress or not yeah and a hat
was pretty cool as well was yeah yeah we
had a lovely time who did you see
camilla and
pinch charles harry and megan
all of them really
what else are you going to do during the
jubilee weekend you're going to go and
see any other events
try to get as close as we can really
wherever you see guys we haven't seen
anyone we literally just got here
because it's so sad but we've got red
white and blue yeah
thank you this gentleman yeah no we
didn't see anything today but yesterday
we couldn't get anywhere near uh
the mouth so we ended up walking around
the back of victoria and then we got
stopped by outriders and the queen came
from eaton square went through that
little back gate did you get away well
we did i thought i'd video but sadly i
got the bumper because i was too excited
a picture of the bumper
yes can you see it um
what you've managed to see i know it's
the queen's body exactly exactly
[Applause]
what did you see yesterday um yeah we
saw everything you know uh all the
people going past and you know the uh
all the cars going oh sorry and then i
looked at all the cars coming through
and we saw kate and she was waving we
thought she was waving
i'm sure she was
i'm sure
so lovely it was magical fantastic
amazing how many flags have you got
three or four oh thank you you've done
very well
well done bye
um i saw a little glimpse of prince
harry and megan which i was really
pleased to see and i'm glad they got a
really nice reception so yeah she was
looking fabulous
could you work out what she was wearing
because i'm not good at that um a dress
really nice um cream sort of coat dress
very the shoes were very stylish oh you
could see the shoes
i am i am right outside of washington dc
and we're so excited to be here our
daughter lives in london now yes we're
super excited fantastic who did you see
um well we were at the mel yesterday and
we saw pretty i mean as much as we could
the ceremony was incredible everybody's
been so friendly and so wonderful it's
been super cool i am from florida my
nonprofit the st georgia society of palm
beach has donated a thousand trees to
liverpool through the queen's green
canopy
so i was here to see trees in liverpool
and then come down for this event as
well and who did you see them where i
think did you
i'm sure my cameras did but i couldn't
lovely people behind you are they come
this way
what were you going to say i just didn't
say it so wonderful how enthusiastic
everybody is what have you seen so far
we've seen a lot of cars we didn't
actually see anybody get out the cars
because we were a bit late but we've
just come for the atmosphere okay well
you'll see them leave it yes if you get
yourself a good position yeah yeah yeah
the queen would ask how far have you
come we've come from canada in
staffordshire there you go
did you come because hello
[Laughter]
you're amazing what's your name hi hi i
was named after the queen and i'm
elizabeth you're elizabeth as well how
old are you elizabeth i'm six you're six
you look seven and how old are you i'm
ten and your name is alicia alyssia and
who's this
this is susan the first corgi that's
susan and see she knew it was the first
corgi first call it the queen adored
susan didn't she yeah where did you get
susie um
nice song yeah it was a gift from mummy
and daddy i'm guessing was it a little
medal yeah lovely lovely i don't know
why i'm holding the mic there for the
dog
lovely to see you girls thank you so
much ten years ago yeah the queen's um
for the queen's diamond jubilee yeah um
i was i was a baby and i met the queen
because she came to birmingham no
and i was known as the jubilee baby no
that's amazing who is here with you
who's here with you
mom doesn't want to be on the camera no
yeah she's just waving that's fine
that's fine well it's lovely to see you
both girls
that's great thank you very much thank
you i'm going to be seven in two weeks
oh you see i thought you looked seven i
thought you looked seven when are the
teeth coming back do you think what i
want for my birthday is my two friends
hey
fantastic you want to wave and say hi to
everybody because you'll be on sky news
there you go hello to everybody back
home
where's susan the corgi look after
yourselves girls make sure you get back
to mom please there you go fantastic
there you go
thanks mum
hi can we just take one picture you're
live yep hi everyone we're from super
drugs some pools okay we just got told
by an area manager to come and visit
can you take a picture of us yeah
there
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hi i would like to say hello to my
mom in portugal in lisbon my brother my
brother michael my sister edna thank you
very much i'm very happy to be here
there we go and everybody else that
knows him uh who else have we got to
talk to where have we got to go to let's
go a little bit further down here and
chat to another couple of people
hi did you manage to say you're live on
sky at the moment did you manage to see
anything yes yes i managed to see it so
it was very very nice i was i'm really i
don't know flutter i i don't have words
it's amazing i'm so happy to be here
today seriously and it's just fantastic
um i'm just waiting now to see when they
coming out where have you come from
italy oh yes italy whereabouts in italy
napoli oh fantastic yes and you've come
here especially for like well actually i
i live here
yes i'm not living far so yeah i was
here since this morning just to have
that opportunity to to see us amazing
would you like to have a very quick chat
with us did you oh you don't want to i
don't know
what did you manage to see
uh we just we got here a little bit late
so we basically just see people like
walking in the royals you know yeah we
we also like from london and we just you
know i was working yesterday so we was
just like okay we have to get up early i
have to see it like i'm not personally
british sounds like that may be my only
chance to see a royal family and i just
really wanted you know to have it so now
we're waiting and they're gonna exit the
caterer and i think i'm gonna have some
good shots you know it's a pretty good
spot so yeah hopefully yeah i think
you'll see them coming down the stairs
yeah in saying that alistair oh they
will be coming down in about an hour
have you seen that union flag there do
you think we can get in there i think we
can try really quickly can we just
squeeze through oh yes this gentleman
here can we just squeeze through a
little bit and we'll we'll leave you to
it and just hello sir
you're live on sky we just wanted to
talk because you've got your union flag
around your neck and your shoulders i
should say what did you manage to see
not a lot from here unfortunately we
haven't got a good view we did see from
the distance
yeah but why did you decide to come
today
we came for the last one as well for the
golden so we wanted to do this one
fantastic and how long have you been
here for we arrived yesterday
and you're staying for sunday
yes okay great to see you lovely thanks
very much indeed maybe if we can just
lift up there and uh show ed uh the
number of people i'll be with you in one
second i'll be with you one second i'll
be with you one second okay
my mother-in-law mrs ann hall black hill
concert thinks you're the best presenter
on television well she's fabulous i
think
it's nice to see
thanks very much indeed we'll be back in
just a second